[music playing]
OK, this is going to be tight.
BEAR GRYLLS (VOICEOVER):
Comedian and actor
Joel McHale and I are trying
to navigate a deep slop
canyon in the Arizona desert.
Oh my god.
BEAR GRYLLS (VOICEOVER): But it
just became dangerously narrow.
Oh, I'm stuck.
[grunts]
Keep going.
Wriggle, keep wriggling.
[grunts]
I'm fine, Bear.
You go ahead.
JOEL MCHALE: I'm, you
know, a larger man,
and there's a lot
of tight crevices.
This is not a hike for those
that enjoy pizza all the time.
So now this is--
this is all from flash
flood here, like barbed wire
and everything.
Yeah, it's going
to get very tight.
Yeah, you think?
BEAR GRYLLS: It's been getting
progressively narrower.
You know, it kind of
gives you that little bit
of claustrophobic feeling.
And this is one of the ones
where you just got to take
your time with because
the danger of slot canyons
is you get caught in
them, you get committed,
and then you can't get back out.
[grunts]
Can I just stay here?
Sure.
See you later.
Bear, this is-- you
can't leave me for dead.
I have a number of stand-up
dates at some pretty
prominent local casinos.
Keep going, Joel.
Keep moving.
OK, I'm coming through.
I'm all right.
I'm fine.
OK, hey, we did it.
Yeah, looking good.
Piece of cake.
Yes, piece of cake, a very
thinly sliced piece of cake.
JOEL MCHALE: Bear, he--
he just runs off, and
then I have to catch
up with him all the time.
I guess that's how it
works on this show.